hey guys Pete here today I'm gonna talk
about the ending of Westworld season 3 I
mentioned in my preview video for this
episode that there was a lot riding on
this finale as to whether it was gonna
be a good season or not and overall I
enjoyed the ending so I thought I'd make
a video this should go without saying
but this video will contain spoilers for
everything that's happened in the West
World Series right through the
post-credits scenes in season 3 episode
8 if you haven't watched the finale this
video won't be for you
we've been outside the Park West world
and we've been following Deloris Prime
the first host that Arnold created for
the park 37 years ago along with some
coffee she made of herself to help with
her plans in the real world season 3
also introduced the company insight
which was created by the new character
Ciroc to use big data to bring order to
the world through algorithmic
determinism in other words Dolores broke
free of her loop escaped the park and
learned that humans were basically on
loops themselves throughout the season
it wasn't exactly clear what Dolores was
trying to accomplish or why she chose
Caleb Nichols a human Rehoboam
designated as an outlier to team up with
we learn in the finale that her plan
wasn't to exterminate the human race but
to save them from being locked into
fates that were determined by artificial
intelligence she wanted to give humans
the same thing dr. Ford gave her a
chance to leave behind their loops and
experience free will she tells caleb
freewill does exist it's just [ __ ]
hard and she lays out her motivations in
a conversation with Maeve where she's
trying to get her to come on to her side
she tells her so many of my memories
were ugly but the things I held on to
until the end weren't the ugly ones
I remember the moments where I saw what
they were really capable of moments of
kindness here and there and they knew
enough of beauty to teach it to us maybe
they can find it themselves but only if
you pick a side Maeve there's ugliness
in this world disarray I choose to see
the beauty this is a phrase she's used
from the very introduction of the
character but here we can see it in a
different light when we first met her
this reflected the night
nature of the ranchers daughter and now
it's a vision ground that an experience
about the future by using this phrase we
can see the Dolores character has come
full circle as to why she chose Caleb we
learned that they had crossed paths
years ago inside park 5 in the season 3
finale we learned that park 5 was used
for military training so it was
different from the other parks we've
seen like Westworld
while their caleb stopped soldiers in
his company from having their way with
Dolores Hana Rio and other hosts that
were used as background players in their
training his act made an impression
showing Dolores that while caleb was
able to be violent he could also choose
to be kind he had the ability to choose
Ciroc on the other hand gave up his
ability to choose
he gave up control of his
decision-making to Rehoboam
because in his view humans are
disorganized and prone to chaos he tells
me that he lived in the chaos and that
now he chooses to listen to obey and to
his credit he stuck with this all the
way to the end where he found himself
bleeding out in front of his creation he
tells Caleb he can't be the one in
control because he's nothing more than a
dangerous sociopath aka an outlier that
only managed to have a semblance of a
life because Rahab owned gave it to him
in the end Ciroc is locked out of his
creation just like he locked his brother
Jean me out of his caleb decides to use
his access to rehab
to have it destroy itself he tells it to
execute the final command erase yourself
this happens and in the pre credits
ending of the finale we see Caleb and
Maeve looking out at Los Angeles with
explosions going off across the
landscape Maeve delivers the line we
first heard her say back in season 1
this is the new world and in this world
you can be whoever the [ __ ] you want the
lorises vision is realized and based on
the explosions
it looks like Ciroc might have had a
point with the whole prone to chaos idea
he was pushing her vision may have lived
on but Dolores prime apparently did not
host death isn't as cut and dry as that
of humans but for all intents and
purposes that version of Dolores died
when her memories were erased we see her
disappear from the
conversation with Maeve and when Caleb
ordered Rehoboam
to delete itself that should be the end
of anything else that existed in that
original host that Arnold built
does that mean that Evan Rachel Wood
won't return for season 4 or that a host
Dolores won't be part of the story
that's something the finale didn't
answer personally I think that's
unlikely the show kind of revolves
around Dolores and Evan Rachel Wood does
a great job of portraying her she's
certainly a fan favorite but one thing
the finale did show us is that those
copies Dolores made of herself are not
the same as Dolores prime the most
surprising twists of the season 3 finale
came from the copy of Dolores that
resides in the hosts body that looks
like Charlotte Hale char Laura's evolved
to be a completely unique entity and in
the end goes in her own direction she
even took time to take control of
Dolores prime to show us that she's
powered up and by the end it's pretty
clear that she'll be leading a new army
of hosts that she's building in the
post-credits scene she tells the man in
black that she and Dolores prime started
in the same place but that she can now
see the error of the path that prime
took she lorises plans for the future
aren't spelled out clearly by the end of
season 3 but from what we do see she's
got a ton of resources at her disposal
and she's putting a plan into action
William aka the man in black was the
other big casualty of the finale his
human form is killed off by a host
version in that char Laura's built this
means that Ed Harris should continue to
have a starring role in the series but
human William is dead and sure Laura
says that he will save the world but
adds for us to the end of it referring
to the host some things to keep in mind
the Dolores mechanical body still exists
but the memories from her Dolores prime
build are gone there are still multiple
copies of her out there there's char
Loras there are the two pearls that were
in Connells and Musashi both of which
should be in Charla's possession now and
there is the one that was in the
Lawrence body whose
location is a mystery going into season
four none of these will amount to a
replacement of the character we've
watched Evan Rachel would play for three
seasons though whether or not this means
that Evan Rachel Wood will continue to
play a role in the series is unknown but
I will just throw it out there that dr.
Ford died at the end of season one and
that was not the last time we saw
Anthony Hopkins on screen the final
character left to discuss is Bernard or
more accurately Bern Arnold a
combination of the host named Bernard
that dr. Ford built and the man he was
based on Arnold Weber Ford's partner and
co-creator of the hosts it turns out
that Bernard was the one who had the key
that Ciroc had been looking for the
whole time he's visited by the Dolores
copy and Lawrence's body and given a
device that allows him to access the
sublime or the valley beyond he tells
Stubbs that he was wrong about Dolores
she wasn't trying to exterminate the
human race she was trying to save it he
says that mankind was always racing
towards this end in that what Ciroc and
his brother were doing was just holding
it off Stubbs calls it an apocalypse and
Bernard counters that the host had to
burn down their world to be free as well
he then uses the key to access the
sublime looking for an answer to the
question what comes after the end of the
world
so Bernhard survives and that keeps the
sublime safe it's also interesting to
remember that Bernard and by extension
the parts of Arnold that are inside this
host that we call Bernard now would in
fact remember Dolores prime and there's
definitely a chance that he could
rebuild her in the same way that she
rebuilt him
the final post-credit scene is Bernard
waking up in the same motel room covered
in enough dust to tell us he's been
there for some time we see him come back
online with no definitive answers for
how long he was gone or what he might
have learned in the valley beyond it's
an interesting question considering that
the valley beyond was created to give
the host who made it there like a catchy
taw and Teddy a world of their own to
build something free of human
influenced by going there he's going to
see what they came up with and Bernard
will definitely have something to share
with the world after he returns but it's
anyone's guess who will still be around
to share it with so to wrap things up
Kaleb and Maeve are alive and will
continue to see how the lorises Vision
plays out Ciroc was bleeding out the
last time we saw him but we didn't see
him die on screen so maybe he won't
Rehoboam his creation however has been
destroyed sure Loras has plans to make
sure that hosts survive we see that she
has a lot of resources but we don't know
what her endgame is that she has in mind
beyond just making sure that hosts
aren't exterminated from the planet
human man in black is dead but he has a
host version that lives on which is
under the control of sho Loras and
Dolores prime is gone but there's
several different ways where we may see
a different version and Evan Rachel
would return for season four and with
that I'll leave it there please like
this video if you enjoyed it tell me in
the comments what you thought of the
finale what you thought about season
three overall I liked the ending a lot
better than I liked the rest of the
season if I'm being honest it looks like
we're gonna have at least the season
four maybe going up to six seasons so
let me know what you think about that
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
I'll talk to you soon